top political issue of the day so
important I found this out from Jezebel
and then this too was going all around
the internet Halle Berry a very talented
actress might play a trans man what is a
trans man a trans man is a woman who
thinks that she's a man so Halle Berry
an actress might pretend to be somebody
who she is not which is I believed last
time I checked that's what actors do and
actresses moreover Halle Berry an
actress will pretend to be another woman
pretending to be a man but when a woman
pretends to be a man in reality that is
sacred that is wonderful and few
question that you're a bigot but when an
actress pretends to be another woman on
the stage which is her job that is evil
and terrible and wrong that is our
upside down culture that we're in I mean
they go on they say Halle Berry is
either ignoring or is it not gotten the
message that trans characters should be
played by trans actors but she is quite
effusive about her wish to play a trans
man in an upcoming project so so trans
characters should be played by people
who want to pretend to be other things
not by actresses who by definition
pretend to be other things I see
Scarlett Johansson's experience has
taught her nothing and that was two
years ago Scarlett Johansson got caught
in some trouble with this because a few
years ago she also wanted to play a part
of someone who is confused about his his
or her gender and but listen to the
threat there Scarlett Johansson's
experience has taught her nothing it's
this pressure look what we did Scarlett
Johansson will do it to you you got to
stop it you got to go along with the
system whatever it says
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description